I want to back a little bit with their
tradition and offer the first question
to the floor there's a young reporter
aptly and he's called Jack Callahan Jack
can we have your first question please
jack hi I'm Jack and I'm 15
from interfilm I'm George I went at how
important it is to make socially
conscious films that appeal to my
generation well it's a good question
actually that's a very good question
you guys are you a little embarrassed
right now you know it's I think it is
important to do that I don't I don't
know that you always set out to do those
films I've done several films that
probably weren't very inspirational to
15 year olds but but this one I thought
I liked the message and I thought the
idea of when I was growing up when I was
your age I growing up in a period of
time where the idea was that your voice
not the famous person's boys not a
politician boys but the individual voice
could change the world could and we saw
it happen we saw Rosa Parks on a bus we
saw we saw things change and we believed
when I was growing up that we had the
ability to do that I think over time
we've lost sight of that a little bit
and I think it's always good and I think
it's really important to make a film
like this that gets to say you know your
individual voice the future is not
inevitable and and what seems very dark
and gloomy doesn't necessarily have to
be we created it we can change it and it
doesn't have to just be the people in
the greatest amount of power it can be
you know a 15 year old young reporter so
I think it's important to make them but
I'm but I'm glad that you got to ask
that question thanks and I question for
the panel for the filmmakers for Brad
and Damon and Jeff I'm sure that
everybody in this room has a favorite
Disney film and I just wondered
in what ways does Tomorrowland a world
beyond
in what ways is it stayed very true to
walk Disney's vision and unto his values
Brad would you like to make sure I think
that he had a Walt Disney as an
individual had a
a view of the future that it was
undecided but exciting it was something
that could be fun it was something that
that where science wasn't the enemy it
was actually a just another thing to
play with and be inspired by so I think
that in the loosest sense we were trying
to make a film that kind of came from
that camp it's not a film about the
section of Disneyland
that is called Tomorrowland it's more
about the idea of what tomorrow could be
Damon and Jeff would you like to join in
that yeah I think there's also a big
part of Disney and and what and what
Walt's vision for what that word would
come to mean that was sort of associated
with magic and for us you know we didn't
want to make a movie that had any magic
in it we did want to ground it in
reality but but that is very much a part
of what a Disney film is that idea of
when I first saw Mary Poppins being able
to jump into the sidewalk and so I think
that we try to take those the idea that
Brad was just talking about and marrying
it to something that was a little more
fun a little more adventurous George
jumping into a sidewalk we thought it
was kind of a penny we cut that part he
did his own stunts
yeah I'm Jeff would you like to answer
that question yeah I mean just to add to
that researching Disney history was a
huge part of our brainstorming process
finding ideas finding inspiration and
things like Walt's original plan for
Epcot as a as a place that would be an
actual living laboratory for scientists
and industrialists and artists coming
together to find ideas to make the world
a better place or something very
inspiring and idealistic about that that
that inspired a lot of the things that I
think are pretty evident in the film and
if we could just go to our cast night
and George you said that the optimism
appeal to you and so much about they the
film was you know on the on the script
and on the page but also to Britt and
Ann terrific what about the scale of the
film that stuff George you've been on a
few film sets in your time I mean why
does this compare oh this little
independent film yeah
huh it's a big one it was big I mean the
the fun part for us is that oftentimes
when you do when you work on a film
that's of a large scale it's all just
green-screen I mean you guys been on
sets like that before it and you don't
really get any idea of the scope and we
were in places that you either we had
these giant beautiful sets that we got
to actually see or we were in you know
Valencia and in that insane building
that I've never seen anything like it
which is also a very much of a dreamer
who built that so Calatrava you mean
yeah yeah yeah it's unbelievable so I
think that I think for I think all of us
the fun part was that we got to see some
of the scope as opposed to having it put
in later and CGI I think that was fun
when then yeah yeah would you like sense
from that but she was sure um I you know
I think there were so many scenes that I
had even just by myself you know
sometimes with green screen and I
haven't done a lot of that at all but
sometimes at least you have actors to
work off of I often times would just be
you know doing scenes by myself whether
it be in a wheat field or what-have-you
and and it was so helpful that we had
you know someone who planted all of this
wheat for miles and miles for me to fly
over and react to because I really do
think that it elevated the film and the
performances but yeah just being a part
of it was really incredible
roughy yeah I thought that it was really
fun and and all the sets were amazing
because each time you like to each spot
something new and they're just really
cool and because it was so big everybody
became like a family and it was just
really fun it's great and Brad just
before we open it to the floor and I
wondered what you if you could just tell
us a little bit about your background
and animation and higher informs your
live-action films of course we're all
great fans of The Incredibles the Iron
Giant and ratatouille
the question was what your background in
animation you know how to inform sure
your live-action films um I think it
helps in just pre visualizing stuff in
animation you you kind of have to know
what
you want and and it helps to be able to
draw things to show people you know what
what you're doing so in this film where
we were dealing with a lot of things
that partially were there and partially
weren't you know the sequence where
Britt touches the pen and spends you
know several minutes with no cuts kind
of in Tomorrowland all of that had to be
planned and some of it was there and
some of it wasn't but we had to know
what we had to know everything that was
there because the camera is constantly
moving from something that's there to
something that's not and following
something that's not there and that
leads you to something that is there and
and animation help with that definitely
that's great ladies and gentlemen we
opened it to the floor and there's a
gentleman the front grille here he's got
the first question excuse my voice I'm
just back from Karen my body hates me
I've got a question for everyone for my
son who's 10 years old he would like to
know if you had a key that could even
show you something or take you anywhere
where would you go why would you go
there Thank You Robby where would you go
I'd go to a forest that was filled with
trees and wolfs so then I could become
like a wolf lady my friends and then I
think Oh with jetpacks out of jetpacks
Jeff back course yeah Wayne's good do
better than that
ah ah - so where'd you go I mean it's
not as good as rats but um I'd love to
go on a nice vacation to the Maldives I
would love to spend some time there I
hear it's beautiful because I'd love to
go like diving with with you know
underwater animals I think that'd be
really cool that's all I got sorry
anyone else got an answer I'm not gonna
come up with anything better than then
don't in the wolf I know
the wolf wind is really good to wolf in
a jet pack well yeah what I want to hear
more about yeah
I want to horror more about do we give
the jet packs to the wolves or what
exactly is happening here we create an
animal that was mixed to the jet pack so
it's like a wolf set yeah
I surrender man you're answering all I
got you also have a new film what you
see yeah well back good there is good
anybody else from the end of the table
like to yesterday I'm not gonna try to
talk that about well that is work yeah
we really enjoyed the front row here the
man next to you has had a massive
success behind the camera as well as in
front of the camera yeah thanks for that
refresher mmm
are you looking to follow the same path
do you want to move into writing and
directing and producing as well ooh um
maybe I would be like maybe you know 30
years from now I have a lot I just think
I'm not as advanced as you my friend I
need more time to backtrack here I guess
uh yeah I mean it definitely interests
me but I just feel like there you know
if I if I did it I would want to do it
well and I need more experience and I
need to work with more people like him
and Brad and you know this whole group
of people everyone's so amazing on this
film and I just hope to do more films
like this you know and gain some
experience take it you know one step at
a time at this point you know and John
my brother your name has become
synonymous with family movies now people
don't think of children's movies movies
but the family movie seems to be very
rare nowadays is there a secret because
you all the films I'm thinking but I
like
you've often been connected with is
there a secret to that all ages appeal
if there is I wish I knew it because I
have no idea I'm just like that seems
like a good idea it's not a very
intellectual process I mean I think that
movies are tough because you're trying
to connect with people whose lives are
very different just than yours and it's
several years from now and I think that
if you think about it logically there's
no way you would ever try to do the job
and the only way that's ever made any
sense to me is make a movie that I would
want to see and just hope that other
people connect with that okay and this
is generally just here in the front we
would go to the other side yeah it's a
question for Jeff rod and Damon in
crafting such a sort of upbeat adventure
movie and especially one that revolves
around sort of the pursuit of optimism
and the aspiration of optimism is there
a greater statement sort of embedded
within it about the sort of more
pessimistic downbeat nature of tentpole
what Lester's now well I don't think
that any of us set out to turn up our
noses at those films we actually love
those films and on the first in line for
for Hunger Games I'm going to see Mad
Max tonight when we're when we're
finished here I love that stuff but I
but I also feel like we're not seeing
the alternative and I think that so many
of those films while entertaining to
watch I don't want to live in those
realities
I don't want robots trying to kill me or
zombies trying to trying to eat me and
III think that nibble on you may nibble
yeah just that uh but but I think that
Walt lived in a time that was just as
turbulent as the time that we live in
now if not more so and and still he was
able to not just imagine but believe in
our capability as a species to sort of
transcend all that and I kind of feel
like um we we were sort of sitting
around complaining about the fact that
that future didn't exist in film we were
sitting around complaining about the
fact that it's very hard to make an
original film not to not do a sequel or
superhero movie but we weren't doing
anything to make one and so those were
all the ideas this was about kind of
what we could do as opposed to what
everybody else was doing yeah
oh whoa
yeah yeah no I mean I think there's a
line in the film where George's
character is a kid they say you know why
did you make this jet pack and he says I
got tired of waiting around for someone
else to make it for me
I think that's kind of the deal is we
ourselves loved these kind of films that
we're looking up and looking forward and
we're inspired by Close Encounters in a
way we discussed that a lot something
where someone's implanted with a vision
and even though it feels scary at
moments it's actually leading toward
enlightenment and and you know we hope
to make a film like that Jeff would you
like to comment on that utopian rather
than dystopian some of my favorite films
are are dystopian bleak and I think that
some of those movies have a value in
scaring us if you will toward living
differently but again we've seen so many
of those kinds of films in our culture
and I love the idea of making an
original film that was like a
marketplace correction on that and
offering something just different
marketplace correction that's a I think
that's what it's called in Germany is
revenge that's some kind of a Soviet
name isn't it yeah hi my name is Rita
I'm from Finland mr. Clooney I would
like to ask you what was intrigued you
in this script what and you have been
for years known as human rights
activists like Sudan you've been there
and and also concerned about the
environment how would you see tomorrow
let me answer that really quickly we've
been talking trustees in uh I wanted to
work with Brad and I tried to work on
another film earlier before and I would
really wanted to work with Brad and
Damon and they they brought me a script
and and
funnily enough said that they'd written
it with me in mind and then I read the
description and it said you know 55 year
old angry bitter has been kind of you
know I thought really yeah they wrote
that hey handsome
formerly handsome but no the minute I
got the script I wanted to do it I
wanted to work with them I loved the
idea again what we've talked about
before I love the idea of doing an
original film I thought it was very
brave
I love the themes in it I liked the idea
and the argument that that that you know
I grew up in you know in and around News
and I grew up in a time where news was
as bad you know quite honestly if you
think about the 60s there was so many
things going wrong we thought the world
was falling apart with the
assassinations and with the you know
with the civil rights movement and the
race riots and you know the women's
rights movements and everything
everything felt like the world was going
to fall apart and still there was the
Apollo mission you know and there was us
landing on the moon and there was this
this version that we always you know we
always thought it was going to somehow
work out you know and my father used to
as he when he would do the news he would
always try to put things in perspective
and say let's look at you know there's
some there's some skinheads down here
rioting in Cincinnati Ohio there's seven
of them and you cover it because it's a
news story but then you go up to the top
tower 40 stories up and you take a shot
of these seven little people in the
middle of Fountain Square so you
understand in the perspective of the
real world what what really is going on
and I thought that's important because
you know you'll spend a lot of time you
yes I go to Sudan often and South Sudan
now and Darfur is lightning on fire
again and it's a very difficult time in
a lot of these places certainly in
sub-saharan Africa and all over the
Middle East and you'll see these things
and you'll feel just completely
inundated if you watch the news and you
should watch the news but it can't just
be that
there has to be some positive in it
and understanding that for instance the
endeavors that I've taken up we know
will never completely succeed in there's
nope I'll be long dead before they'll be
solved but participating is part of the
game you know getting in and getting
involved and so I boys believed in that
again it was part of what attracted me
to the film question for the three cast
members um you obviously had stomp n to
do the dangerous stunts but I wondered
what did each of you find most scary
that you were asked to undertake well
Raph had all the challenging stuff I
just had to roll around and react to
things being you know shot at me or you
know scary people attacking me uh but I
did I remember there was you were so
good on all the all the ratchets but
there was one ratchet that I had to do
not many um but there was one where I
had to climb up onto the this platform
where I had to go I had the time bomb
and and I remember because I have to
have to be ratcheted up onto this
platform and then I have to lift myself
up onto the platform so that I can stand
and I trained for a really long time
before well not a long time with a month
but a while before we started shooting
just on that specifically and and so it
wasn't that scary but I was just afraid
that I wouldn't be able to pull off you
know the struggle and still be able to
make it on the platform that was like
the biggest challenge for me but you had
all the real stuff to do that was such a
lame answer in comparison never you
train for months and like AB Stefan
yeah I was working on my hair and well I
trained for quite a while on at martial
arts but I was quite because I was like
we work with an amazing scent he was
quite lucky to be able to do quite a lot
of the stuff so and yeah but I never
found it scary because they always made
sure I was comfortable with what I was
doing so I was always just up for yeah
hobbies very brave I trained for minutes
because I had to fight an old other TV
doctor
it was afraid of just getting beaten
with a cane the whole time I think that
was our great stunt wasn't you know I've
got to the point my career it is funny
because when I was in my 30s you know I
used to be the guy that punch somebody
and then walk away with like the
explosion behind you
and now I just get the he'll beat me in
the face might fall down and cry um so
no I I didn't have to do all a lot I
just mostly had to get get beaten up a
lot which was kind of fun for me so I
enjoyed it thank you
and gentlemen the second row here is a
mic here I am Yan from Belgium my
question is for mr. Clooney how strange
was it to see the younger actor who
plays the Damini be a little bit just so
you know because probably you don't know
this because you're from Belgium um I
actually played that part too that's how
good I was
yes very convinced I was very convincing
as that part okay yeah it's very I did
yeah it was all he was great why do you
actually I was blond when I was his age
strangely and now I'm getting blond
again that's good fun um but he was
terrific
he was really fun you know I didn't get
to work with him obviously because you
know I would be working with myself
somehow which I don't want to do but
yeah so the really I didn't really get
to see any of it until I saw the film
you know see what he was doing till I
saw the film so it was fun to see what
impersonations of me he was going to do
and there's a gentleman in the third
room we're trying to take these as the
hands go up go ahead yeah hi folks
Steven from from Arlen congratulations
on the film now this could be a question
open to the entire panel but Travel
plays a central role within this
filament of three real wondrous methods
of travel that appeal to both kids and
adults there's the jet packs the
teleportation and the rocket out of the
Eiffel Towers so which would you choose
and to follow after that speaking of
travel George you previously applies to
visit Ireland with Bono at one stage a
couple of months ago and he broke his
eye I believe he said it's one of my
colleagues and he broke his arm and then
that was put back on the back burner so
has not been rescheduled he's a great
anticipation I'll start by saying jet
pack you know it's funny how stories
sort of come go Banas friend and I and
he was in a horrible accident he really
got the hell beaten out of him but he
but we hadn't planned to you know to
come there but I do want to go and I
would like to go sometime you know in
the coming months in the in the warmer
time to go to islet I would like very
much to do it but that wasn't cancelled
because he got in an accident
I he's he's on the mend which is the
good news but I do a jet pack jet pack
don't you think over a rocket cuz rocket
you got a lot of you know what do you
think what would you do what was the
other option show the tone for today
yeah yeah oh that's cool but it's
vibrating and you know you feel kind of
ill after it I I'm jet pack all the way
yeah just if you just to get from the
airport to your house yes and traffic
yeah that would be correct little be
good yeah yeah I get chilly easily so I
probably go with the teleportation yeah
know what to use yeah somebody's got to
take a rocket take a rock I'm gonna take
rocket say go there why not but also
because I remember when we were writing
this story I said there has to be rocket
ships in Tomorrowland I want to go to
space I'd love to go to the moon no much
further than that
okay great a junkman so drug gasps
George the door tear this is an
optimistic film very upbeat very
enjoyable now in your own life
I've been reading quite a few things
that you're enjoying life as never
before
yes would it be fair to say this is the
most optimistic and upbeat
time of your life I mean number one you
bought a house in England that's very
optimistic house he could grow old in
and I never - you've married of course I
said so how do you feel today compared
to a lot like girl you're the last 50
years
well I've always been very optimistic by
the way and I actually have had a very
I've had a very lucky life overall and
been able to do a lot of things that I
never would have imagined I would have
been able to do but it's a very good
time in my life yes I mean a wonderful
time in them and I'm a very lucky man to
have met someone as special as my wife
so I'm very happy and very optimistic
and I'm working on my house as we speak
thank you very much gentlemen but seven
rows back here has got the mic from Tim
yes another question for George what
kind of message would you like this on
here George oh yeah what kind of message
would you like cinema-goers to take away
with from this movie when they've seen
it is there one image one thought you'd
like them to have in your mind I mean I
think that might be a question better
for Brad I think that for me the one
element particularly when you're acting
in film is you know films are designed
as an entertainment you're supposed to
get two hours of relief or something
else other than what you're doing in
your life for the you know so so for me
what you want to take away is two hours
of enjoyment and fun and something to
talk about if along the way you know
you're taking your kids and you get to
walk out and have conversations about
other issues well I think that's a bonus
but I think that would be happy yeah I
mean it's it's not supposed to be sort
of a
horse-sized multivitamin that will solve
all your problems it's supposed to be a
good time at the movies but some of my
favorite movies are movies that stayed
with me after I left the theater and you
know as a war dog yeah yeah yeah a lot
of dystopian films yeah yeah yeah no
it's just you know that's what I love
about cinema is it almost feels like a
dream that you had that was particularly
vivid and it is a dream that you can go
back and revisit and find other sides to
so if we've made that kind of movie that
would be great for me okay there's a
lady here I think on about the fourth
row yes you've got the microphone hello
i'm despina from greece and this is a
question for George and I wanted I know
it's coming I know what it is I bet I do
great nobody can be part of it
part of your answer okay no I wanted to
ask how does your Tomorrowland look like
your ideal future I know it's a big
question so maybe you could mention some
of the things that today might seem you
know impossible and crazy but in the
near future could be possible and what
you were thinking could be one of them
what you thought I was going to I know
what you I think you're gonna ask about
the marbles weren't you oh no no I
thought I was gonna be trouble in
England again with got the Mayor of
London comparing me to Nazis then you
feel like you've really made it oh
really sir I don't know you know what do
I think of the few what do I thinking
for my near future um no I mean how
because I know you know how do you
imagine the ideal future to be is a
really big question sure you could
mention some things that today might
seem impossible or crazy but Ronnie or
for our future could actually you know
be possible that you would like the
people well you know it's interesting I
don't know because when I was growing up
the future seemed like it was gonna be
flying cars and you know all that sort
of things that which didn't happen but
on the other hand we didn't we would
never we never would have thought of
these things either so you know the
world the future you what you with what
you think of it being never really is
but it usually sort of surprises you and
more in more interesting ways I would I
find that there are I would hope that as
we get a little older and get a little
more use to some of our new technologies
that we get away from them a little bit
you know I find that we're yeah you know
I was at a I was at a fundraiser with
the president a few years ago and
everybody there we were shaking hands
with people and everybody there was
shaking hands like this hi how are you
every single person and I remember
saying to him you know they can't really
say they met the president they can say
they filmed him but they didn't we're
you see the concerts now too you know
you're holding up and watching and I
think we're losing a little bit of our
living our life and we're sort of
recording it in a way you have a
recording to watch it later maybe we
watch it or maybe we just send it to our
friends and post up that'll be the
afterlife yeah you just watch what you
record yeah I was like oh my god that
was a great concert I should have seen
it
so I apparently I had a child oh my god
three I I would hope that somewhere in
there we we would get less in love with
our technology and a little bit more in
touch with one another and have
face-to-face conversations and you know
dinner tables we're not everybody's sort
of been locked into those things but you
know that my vision of the future is
sort of getting back to
letter-writing so maybe I've just got
the wrong idea
future it's interesting though because
my oldest boy worked for Apple and just
got a job at uber so he's right in the
high tech sector and his friends and he
go out to dinner and and they put their
cell phones in a stack in that in the
middle of the table when they start the
meal and whoever touches theirs first
has to pay for the meal for everybody so
and this they came up with this
themselves and they're the generation
that is doing the six devices at once
and but I thought that was a really
great solution to that problem our fist
of his conversation is almost over
there's a gentleman in the front row
with the last question well thank you
I'm Marcus from Berlin after question
for the girls and for George how was it
like to drive George Clooney and for
George how was it like being driven by
good a girl or a 12 year old there is a
difference yeah I have been driven by
women's alright close okay crazy
actually but uh but it was a little odd
when you saw Ravi get behind the wheel
it's a little nerve-wracking but she's
actually 36 years old what was it did
you enjoy driving yeah I mean I didn't
get to it and too much but I had driving
lessons and it was felon I remember one
time when we were going down the hill
and and I had to like stop just before
we got to the curb yeah and you weren't
stopped cuz I was like that's alright
well we were on camera yeah I mean okay
trying not to talk is we were on camera
but I really needed her to stop if it
was any other twelve-year-old that would
have been really afraid I'm not gonna
lie but it was Rafi she's very capable
she had the lessons um so it's fine
that's great yeah more 12 year olds are
drive
there's one thing to be gleaned from
this table y'all should be driving get
my license earlier we can make rubber
cars ladies and gentlemen can ask you to
thank our guests this afternoon
you